-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
What a show we got
for you tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this should put you
in an even better mood.
Today is
National Drink Beer Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I understood
when some of my writers
stayed home Monday and Tuesday
for Rosh Hashanah,
but today was pushing it.
It was like, "Really."
Yeah, it's a day
that always starts off fun,
then ends with, "No, Officer,
you have the right
to remain silent."
[ Light laughter ]
Yep, National Drink Beer Day,
and, of course, for all those
who don't celebrate,
there's Coors Light.
Yeah.
[ Laughter, scattered applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Thank you.
Well, guys, today
former president Trump
said that the war
between Russia and Ukraine
would have never happened
if he were in office.
And even --
He even offered to lead peace
talks between the two countries.
Yeah, Trump said, "I'm an expert
on foreign affairs.
I've had affairs
with many foreigners."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just to talk.
Speaking of Trump,
according to a new book,
at one point
during his presidency,
he nearly fired Ivanka and Jared
over Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Eric and Don Jr.
were like, "Wait a minute.
He follows you guys on Twitter?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
Apparently Democratic insiders
are impressed
with Gavin Newsom's recent
criticism of Republicans,
and some think that he's
gearing up to run for president.
[ Cheering, booing ]
It's int-- Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-That was great.
It was like -- 'Cause everyone
was on this side of the crowd
and then -- just very odd, yeah.
I think it's just
very interesting.
'Cause if you put Newsom
in one of those aging apps,
you pretty much get Joe Biden.
And I just thought
that's very interesting.
Very similar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A little tweak up.
Hey, guys, I heard that Kia
recalled 70,000 Sorento
and Sportage SUVs
after multiple reports of fires
and localized melting incidents.
[ Light laughter ]
Kia was like, "Look,
on the bright side,
you now have the world's biggest
panini maker."
So that's pretty good.
I mean...
Apparently, the tow hitch
in the back can melt.
My question is, who's towing
something with a Kia?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Want me to move
that tricycle for you?
Hook her up to the back.
Let's go.
Move that --
Let's go, ant.
Let's go.
We're gonna go down the..."
Well, get this --
McDonald's just announced
that they're going to
start selling Happy Meals
with toys for adults.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
Happy Meals with adult toys.
What could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
For the first time in 10 years,
M&M'S are adding a new character
to the mix, a purple peanut M&M.
Here she is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
A purple peanut M&M.
Yeah, I guess the blue and red
M&M'S date went really well.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Adult toys.
-Alright, alright.
-That's not Grimace.
[ Rim shot ]
-Switching gears,
Pokémon just unveiled
a new character called Wiglett.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
That's one of the toys
in the adult Happy Meal.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-Did you guys see this?
Last night at a concert in D.C.,
Lizzo played
a never-used crystal flute
that once belonged
to President James Madison.
-Ooh.
-No one had played it
in 200 years.
So it was about damn time.
There you go.
That's right.